thank you uh peter we are here indeed
with kirill chefchenko kirill welcome to
the show welcome to the grand chester
what does it mean this opportunity for
you to play against the best chess
players in the world
well first of all i would like to say
a huge thank you to everyone who
made this crunch store possible and for
opportunity to me to give this wild card
to play here i'm the
i'm very excited to play against the top
grand masters and i
can see that i can see their strength
and try to do my best but
of course it's
i had no before that experience to meet
very very top grandmasters but now i
have it so
i'm very happy to be here
and
[Music]
yeah try to show exciting games how
would you say you live the first couple
of days emotionally uh how did you feel
these players
well i think uh
it's quite
unusual because for example i never seen
wesley saw in real life
and so it was very
fine finally i saw them all together
and of course it's very nice to
to
always analyze with them
games and
i'm very happy that
they are very kind to me and we are
discussing uh many different things and
i will
try to
do my best to
uh
get into the granchester next time
yesterday we met at a restaurant and you
told me that in the first day you felt
you played a bit too aggressive yes how
did you change your strategy going into
the second day
well as you can see against anant i
didn't do that and
actually after that loose i decided okay
i will not play
uh too straight forward and
somehow i have to be more calm and
but
today
last game against levon let's talk about
that in fact let's uh look at the last
game against level take us through the
critical game critical points in the
game
well he choose i played the rule lopez
with knight c3
uh he choose the kerry's variation with
d6
and knight g7 it's quite uh
dubious by computer but
it's it seems very
solid because uh he has
very solid structure and so
uh we
played some moves uh and probably that
was the
moment uh well as you see in the game i
give him chance to play knight b6 and
his pawn on e5 is very good safe yes
very safe but maybe knight a4 was uh a
bit better because uh he cannot play
knight b6 no no there's no
c4 yeah and i can play that h4 or
either was c4 is also very interesting
because
here knight b6 i can just go back knight
c3 and already pawn is uh straight to
the knight
so yeah knight b6 and here i realized my
position is kind of worse knight b6 you
take b6 c4 here probably
i was
because about he could play b5 it's very
no no no no not this
maybe here yeah queen d3 here b5 is very
interesting move was
i know there is rook under attack some
uh take and then yeah yeah b5 i guess i
mean uh he played king h8 and bishop g4
he could play also rook a7 is very
interesting move because
now he's writing b5 and then somehow
before c5 is very
uh
he could try to close position and to
get pair of bishops advantage here we
have like kicking h8 rook d1 bishop g4
and i thought my position is totally
worse but after
i played knight h4 g6 knight g2 i
started to think my position is not so
bad because his special bishops are very
passive and after rook d8 f4
uh position becomes very unclear because
like you you see again i go all in but
now now it's
it's might be paid for it because
there's a bit less species on there yeah
you can see bishops are stuck yeah and
levon told me after the game he was also
very surprised that this position is
very is very good for me but somehow my
position if he goes c5 i go d5 and uh
now already my you have some
transmission g5 and if you close g5 i
just take 93 and i have no risk so he
played b5 here is also interesting
moment i thought about bishop b2
probably was interesting but here he can
uh open
much more line files and uh
that would probably help
that was maybe interesting alternative
but i took on b5 b should be took me c6
d5 is also interesting
uh
well can you get stalking h1 was
interesting alternative to d5 because
after d5 queen b6 king h1
looks like f1 bishop eight and he can
hear his ideas choose to play b4 bishop
b5
now i decide okay i have to how do you
feel about your position now i feel are
you confident i felt like uh if i go
uh if i play with uh
with a very aggressive move i shouldn't
be worse but of course in such position
you can be
outplayed because
my king is just too weak but his kick is
also not so
very well defended also another point of
concern for us here in the city as well
as for the guys in st louis was that he
had 12 minutes while you only had three
minutes were you concerned about the
time situation at all yeah i wasn't
very confident at this point to
calculate some very long variations
because i wasn't even sure that my
position is better because
well you can see bishop d7 is much
stronger than knight of g2 and if he
even this point uh levon told me
i could play f5 but here i thought queen
d8
f take g6 king h8 and this position
looks uh
very interesting because i have paul now
but
his g file is open
and
rook c2 is coming i probably will just
comment if i take on h7 you can play
queen s7 or otherwise rook c2 and
position is very complicated that's why
i decided to just
take everything on e5 bishop h3 d6 i was
confident that i am not worth in this
position because my king is not very
weak at all but pawn d6 can create some
stress so i calculated some
small variations like rook fe-8 and
queen f4 probably and the idea
if queen b7 just d7 is winning nice yeah
so yeah rook f2 is very nice move
and here i i've found out yeah i can
give perpetual check yeah queen d5 queen
of queen e5 but i decided to play knight
before it
was
like uh last week i i saw rookie fade
move but here i probably
was too confident that i can find
something but computer shows i don't
have anything perhaps there's always
some sort of perpetual yeah if you think
yeah yeah exactly h3 and then check
check check exactly so he played bishop
g4 queen z5
king g7 knight e6
takes on e6 and here probably that was
like the only chance uh i saw to take on
f2 queen f2 queen d4 but i found this
position is totally draw because rook d5
rook b8 or even b4 king and sacrifice
the ball rookie fight king e6 my king is
completely stuck on king's side
and uh he can just push his pawns and
and it's not very clear who plays will
win absolutely so that was very he
wanted to avoid this yeah because
yeah i didn't see at all because if he
if he tries to
uh refuse the draw he plays this i will
take take a queen h2 and his king is not
in time to block this pawn so very
interesting game very tense and i am
very satisfied that this it was very
um
goodbye computer agents simulation a
solid performance uh today how would you
assess
your overall performance up to this
point
well i still have
some
blunders and some points like with
vishan i blended long castle and it was
i was very curious how could they
blundered this but after that i tried to
get some counter play but it was
impossible
because he defended very well and very
precise
but
yeah i will try to change something but
the last game against levon showed that
not everything is bad yeah
always entertaining chess always a
fighter we're looking forward to see
your games in the next few days thanks
very much guys back to you thank you
christian thank you